hello everyone and welcome to the
candidates tournament of 2018 now I know
what you're thinking with your vast
knowledge of the 1959 candidates
tournament how are you ever to enjoy a
modern events such as the 2018
candidates tournament but I've seen all
the games some of the games are still
being played and all of them seem seem
rather interesting so for the first game
I decided to show again between Fabiano
Caruana and the Westley so so let's see
this game we have d4 Knight to f6 by
Wesley c4 and now II six at the Indian
defense if if Fabiano continues Knight
c3 maybe we would see the the names of
Indian defense but he goes g3 he goes
for the cattle and opening Bishop to b4
check Bishop to b2 blocking and now
Bishop the back 37 it seems like a waste
of a temple for black but the idea is
that white Bishop is a lot less useful
on d2 then it would be NC 1 in the
future white would definitely enjoy
playing b3 maybe develop the Bishop to
b2 so white will also at some point B
will have to lose the tempo to get this
Bishop to another square so Bishop to g2
and now d5 nice to f3
we have castles Fabiana also castles and
now c6
and Queen to b3 Knight B to d7 and now
Bishop to f4 this is the idea now White
has to waste a temple to get the bishop
to a more active Square and F 4 is
definitely a very active square for this
dark square Bishop and here we have a 5
by Wesley there's a little trick
involved with this a 5 move
if Aviano continues it would remove like
Knight to c3 then Wesley has this option
of pushing a 4 and now White has a
problem there's no way for him to defend
it the c4 pawn if the Queen moves black
can simply capture it and if Knight
captures an a4 then D captures on c4 and
again you have to you can't capture the
c4 pawn b5 is coming if you capture it
of course B 5 wins apiece so after a 5
Fabiano doesn't go for any Knight to c3
ideas rather he plays rook to d1 and now
always the plays nice to h5 he wants to
get rid
this very active dark square bishop on
f4 Fabiano brings it back back to c1 and
now Wesley just plays it back Knight to
f6
what's the idea that now this Bishop is
not active at all it's undeveloped and
he invites Caruana
to repeat Bishop to f4 after which was
the would again repeat tonight to h5 and
it would be a draw but Caruana didn't
come to the candidates tournament to
draw with the white pieces and move 12
so he plays Knight B to D to B 5 by
Wesley and now c5 blocking the position
b3 before immediately and this before
move it seems like a great idea you get
to develop your Bishop on a very active
square but there was no need to decide
to do this immediately maybe better was
Queen to c7 and then going after d5
square immediately by pushing a 5 but ok
b4 we have Queen to c2 and now a 4 rook
to e1 and now comes a 5 Knight captures
Knight captures pawn captures and now
Knight to d7 and Wesley did manage to
break karana central pawn structure and
now there's really no way to defend the
c5 pawn and Wesley will win his pawn
back Knight to f3 and here Knight Bishop
captures on c5 and this is something
that might be true might not be true may
be a better idea was capturing would the
knight simply to keep control of the g5
square here was the played Bishop
captures on c5 and now Cara wanna jump
in would Knight to g5 using this very
valuable tempo as now the he threatens
checkmate on h7
so now first of all Wesley has to weaken
his Kings position which he does between
g6 and now we have Bishop to f4 again
developing this Bishop to his active
square and also guarding d5 pawn Queen
to b6 pressuring that f2 pawn but now
karana has the the frame efore move and
now he he gains a lot of control in the
center threatening to capture on d5 also
now the Queen is guarding the f2 pawn so
what's the pushes of b3 we have a
capture some b38
chapter Sun B 3 and now Queen to e2
Bishop to a6 and now Queen to f3 and
this Bishop 3 6 wasn't wasn't the best
idea here probably probably a better
thing was maybe the first developed
would work to a 2 and only then consider
a move like that
now with Bishop to a6 and Queen to f3
karana has a lot of pressure on this f7
pawn which will prove to be very hard to
defend Bishop to c4 now offering an
exchange of rooks and also so that
solidifying in the center but this
doesn't really work in blacks favor as
now after after there is an exchange in
the center then this bishop on c4 would
come in handy as a defensive piece on
the and the f7 threat but you'll see
what actually happens in the game rook
captures an a8 we have rookie actors on
a 8 and now this e 6 move and here it's
extremely hard to play this with black
of course what is threatening to capture
the knight the threat is of course it
captures on f7 would check so wisely
plays the only good move in the position
and that's D captures on e4
this comes with a temple on the Queen
but first black can capture on f7 as
this would check so e captures on f7
would check Bishop captures on f7 now
and now Knight captures on e4 here we
have Bishop to d4 and this was probably
the last moment in the game where Wesley
had a chance to consolidate and maybe
hold this position he had to play Bishop
to d5 immediately to pin this Knight not
allow it to move as the bishop or VI in
the Queen on f3 but instead he played
Bishop to d4
he wanted to get this Bishop back to the
to help out with the defense of the King
and also maybe maybe the Queen would
would find a way to defend the King as
well but he allowed Knight to d6 and now
there's simply too much pressure on
blacks position you can see that the
knight and queen are eyeing f7 so Wesley
immediately gets rid of this Bishop
Bishop to d5 but Bishop to d5 now is a
lot less useful then I move when I
showed you Queen to e2 now and now of
course you can't you can never move the
but for example to capture and you too
because you get win to e6 and you're
getting checkmated so here Wesley tried
night to a fete and night to a fete to
keep an eye on the e6 square but
unfortunately this doesn't work here car
wanna plate but should CalPERS on d5
this is would check pawn characters on
d5 and now Queen to f3 and here there's
really not a good good move for black
there are simply too many threats this
Bishop can move either to age 60 35 the
queen is coming to f7 you can't play a
move like Queen to c7 to bring the Queen
over to help out with the defense
because of Queen captures any e on d5
would check picking up the bishop on d4
and if you try something like Queen to
a7 to still keep an eye on the King side
and also to guard the bishop on d4 also
doesn't work because now Queen captures
on b5 which check King moves and now
Bishop to e5 would check you have to
capture it as a white would capture a
bishop on d4 so but should capture
screen captures King to g8 Queen to d5
check King to g7 and now Knight to b5
and now the game is over
your queen is attacked your rook is
attacked and you have to keep an eye on
the seventh rank or the Queen because if
you don't you allow rook to e7 so you
don't really have a move here if you
move twin B agent immediately rookie 7
check is coming King to h6 and now h4
and there is really no defense against
Queen to g5 checkmate you would have to
start giving up pieces
so after this Queen to have to remove
Wesley tried another idea he tried Queen
to a5 to keep an eye on the d5 pawn and
also to attack the row Connie one but
this simply doesn't work because this
allows the white to simply bring bring
the rook straight into the attack here
Fabiano played rook to e7 and it was in
this position that Wesley so resigned to
the game and the victory in round 1 of
the 2018 candidates goes to Fabiano
Caruana
and maybe there will be a more decisive
results not all games have yet finished
why did he resign here there is no
defense against all the threats I will
just show a couple of lines as the ideas
are very interesting
so what really
all white has to do is move this bishop
and M Queen to f7 is coming and it's all
over
so black can try and stop this well he
can't really he if you go something like
Bishop to g7 then it's it's a forced to
checkmate him for rook captures King
captures Bishop to e5 check King moves
and now Knight to f7 is checkmate and if
you don't capture the rook if you have
to look at first on g7 you move then
it's another another very nice checkmate
night to f7 you give up the rock on g7
King captures now Bishop to e5 check
King moves and now Knight to h6 that's
checkmate so all very nice ideas and if
you try to move like King to h8 simply
to not allow the Queen to jump into f7
with tempo again you get night to f7
check King moves Knight to h6 check King
moves and now Bishop to e5 you give up
the bishop so the Queen can jump to f7
Bishop captures and now Queen Queen to
f7 and there is no defense against Queen
to GA check or if you move the knight so
the rock would defend g8 then you get
Queen - h7 checkmate
so all very nice ideas and like black
can only give two checks here after
Queen e1 King G to Queenie for checking
h3 there are no more checks as the
knight is covering f5 and g4 so a very
nice game by Fabiano Caruana
but mostly it's mostly it's due to
wesley missing a couple of critical
ideas so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it
and I think I will also cover iron hand
versus ding leerin from round one is
it's a also a very crazy game so yeah I
would like to thank lemma Mauro
Linamar Oh again William Jones mano a
balla Subramani
Oscar smacking pradeep's a Kakuna soft
pressure and Oliver taught law for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
I probably from another game from the
candidates but tomorrow morning it's
back to the tall vs. BOTS eunuch series
and the famous game 6 so thank you all
and I will see you soon